à
[Musique]
on m'a partir plus sûr du bouquet
aujourd'hui sur du bouquet aux couleurs
en hauteur ça te changera du bouquet ray
et après on passera sur une composition
auteur aussi quand elle est en
entreprise avec son maître
d'apprentissage anaïs est tout près du
but qu'elle s'est fixé devenir fleuriste
pour elle comme pour beaucoup d'autres
l'apprentissage c'est une somme de
compétences de formation différente qui
toutes convergent vers un même objectif
j'avais un c'est après vente et après
j'ai aimé j'aimais bien la nature
j'aimais bien le langage des fleurs
et puis la créativité du coup je me suis
lancé dans l'apprentissage en corse
le métier de l'artisanat redevient à la
mode 1 c'est vrai que il y aura toujours
besoin de fleuriste donc je pense que
l'apprentissage c'est une bonne chose ah
si anaïs peut laisser libre cours à son
imagination en entreprise à l'école
il faut aussi et d'abord apprendre les
fondamentaux du métier et des outils
année qu'annick d'un bouquet la façon de
manipuler une fleur de couper une tige
maintenant non
comme ça non non regarde simplement tu
te synthétique comme ça quand tu viens
tu irais avoir comme enseignante une
fleuriste meilleur ouvrier de france ça
ouvre des perspectives ça donne en tout
cas une certaine vision du métier je
veux pas que ce soit vraiment trop
scolaire j'aimerais que ça sorte de ses
quelque chose le métier artistique c'est
quelque chose qui est qui et
l'émotionnel donc c'est ça je veux
simplement qu'ils prennent plaisir à
toucher les fleurs il faut être très
observateur il faut avoir des dons de
coloriste parce que on travaille
énormément la couleur il ya des bons
côtés il ya des mauvais côtés on ne fait
pas que des beaux bouquets artistique
c'est lourd on travaille dans le froid
on travaille les jours fériés
on n'y a pas que du positif mais quand
on aime on ne compte pas et puis suivre
les conseils d'une professionnelle
distingué au plus haut niveau si ça
n'est pas les petits accidents ça
participe quand même à cette volonté de
donner une autre image de
l'apprentissage
c'est vrai que l'apprentissage une
connotation malheureusement encore un
peu aujourd'hui deux voies de garage
mais c'est en train de changer ça change
et on le voit nous on le vit tous les
jours puisque c'est une voie porteuse re
en matière d'emploi on sait
qu'aujourd'hui un jeune qui s'orientent
en apprentissage à sept chances sur dix
de trouver un emploi à la fin de sa
formation
et ça se concrétise tous les jours il ya
aujourd'hui une centaine d'apprentis
fleuriste à l'école des métiers une
centaine de vocations encore en boutons
n'est qu'ils ont toute l'ambition
d'éclore un jour les apprentis auront
pour samy toutes les chances de leur
côté